[Music]
[Music]
what do I do when I feel unfocused or
overwhelmed there are a few things first
I have a short checklist am i eating
enough all right so it's very
fashionable with intermittent fasting to
skip breakfast skip that meal skip
another meal for myself I've realized
unless I am in ketosis unless I'm on a
ketogenic diet or fasting or have
ketones in my blood which is an
alternate fuel to glucose I need to eat
and of course you can supplement with
exogenous ketones but am i eating enough
if I skip breakfast and it's 1 p.m. and
I haven't had lunch and I'm feeling
unfocused or overwhelmed I probably
don't need to sit there and journal on
my existential dilemmas I need to eat
some [ __ ] macadamia nuts and maybe
have some beans or salad or something
like that all right it's a simple simple
simple the second would be am i
consuming too much caffeine real simple
for me if I'm feeling anxious
overwhelmed very often if I want to
achieve a more zen-like state there are
at least two things I can do and one is
meditate twice a day which I like to do
doesn't always happen meditate twice a
day and do all of these other things
related to cultivating peace of mind the
second one is stop consuming so much
caffeine alright real real real simple
then last are a few tactical and
strategic questions and being
overwhelmed and unfocused I think are
quite different things typically
sometimes they come along together there
are two questions or I should say two
pairs or groups of questions that I use
a lot the first one is an 80/20 analysis
and there are two questions as part of
them and I put this on paper always on
paper because I want to trap my thoughts
on paper to see if they hold any weight
see if there's any insight to see what
is ridiculous maybe I have worries that
once I put them down or really unfounded
and kind of ludicrous first question is
what are the 20% of activities or people
that are producing 80% or more of the
results and positive emotional states
that I want the positive
emotional states part is really
important all right so you spend one or
two pages on that the second part is the
opposite what are the 20% of activities
responsibilities or people that are
producing 80% or more of the pain the
headache and the negative emotional
states that I would prefer not to have
do another page or two and then the last
question if you're engaged with a
specific project or relationship could
be anything really it's very simple what
would this look like if it were easy a
thing if we're type A personality we've
competed in school we've competed next
we've competed in y&z we are trained by
ourselves to believe that if we're not
red lining if we're not overcome with
effort that we're not doing a good job
we're not trying hard love and I think
that often leads us to seek complicated
paths with many many moving pieces so
what would this look like if it were
easy so for instance if I'm having
trouble with a book and I have three
months left to write it I'll ask myself
what would this look like if it were
easy what if I had to finish this book
in a week if I had a gun to my head or a
gun to my dog's head or Mohali and I had
to save Molly what would I do all right
you have a week that's it period how
would you write this book and that
carrot gets rid of a lot of fluff and I
started saying all right well how can I
use money instead of time to fix this
problem how could I ask other people for
help instead of trying to do it all
myself in this situation what would this
look like if it were easy and you can
find a lot of gems that way and just
expect 95% of you write down is going to
potentially be ludicrous and you should
come up with the absurd right don't edit
when you're putting stuff down but
within that you might find one or two
things and you're like that's it now I
can save 80% of my headache 80% of my
angst because I don't have to do it the
hard way and then you can find an
elegant solution that produces an even
better product even better outcome so
those are a few of the things that I
regularly do when I'm feeling over well
or unfocused or distracted hey guys if
you're enjoying the tips and tactics and
how-to on this channel or in the podcast
the Tim Ferriss show I made this for you
try the mentors short advice from the
best in the world this is the book that
I wanted to read so I went out and I put
it together created a dream list a
hundred and thirty of the best at what
they do people who are icons legends and
asked them all the same questions these
are people in some cases I wanted to
reach out to my whole life ranges from
many many billionaires cofounders of
every company imaginable elite athletes
ranging from surfing to tennis to
powerlifting everything else country
stars actors directors and you can spot
the pattern so some of my friends have
said this is the easiest to read most
useful book that I've put together yet
so check it out tribe of mentors dot-com
you can find sample chapters the whole
list of mentors everything tribe mentors
calm